it is time for hatred mail what is
hatred mail quick reminder of course the
right of the people to keep and bear
hates shall not be infringed Patriot man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom
this week's hatred mail deals with a
topic that it's sort of a silly topic
but it is more and more a part of the
emails that I'm getting from the
audience take a listen to this Americans
are not so stupid as you David they will
never go socialist little less talk
David more listen enough was stupid milk
how can you take this Pakman dude
seriously is that even his real hair I
have no idea why I'm still subscribed to
this tripe yeah so despite it looking
insane this is my real hair people who
watch the show have been noticing that
it's been months since I've gotten a
haircut I just haven't had time I've had
a lot of weekend travel combined with
all of the livestreams impeachment
election live streams State of the Union
a whole bunch of different stuff so it
could be a very long time until I get
myself a haircut the haircut plan is not
going well but it is indeed my real hair
don't worry remember that you can fight
hate reott ism by using the coupon code
hey tree at 40 when you sign up at join
pakman.com use the code h 80 our i OT
4-0 you save 40 percent and 40 hey tree
'it's cry every time that coupon code is
used